the american military launches a
full-scale public attack on tucker
carlson
team biden pushes a new era of big
government on the back of lies about an
endless
pandemic and the grammys was a full of
pornography i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you
visit expressvpn.com ben alright we'll
get to all the news in
just one moment first let's be real
about this you're paying way too much
for your cell phone coverage
okay the reality is that when you go to
get coverage they will tell you that
what you need is unlimited talk
uh unlimited talk and unlimited text and
unlimited data but here's the thing you
don't actually need unlimited data
because you're not going to use
unlimited data because it is unlimited
data instead
here is what you need unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data at 30 bucks
a month this is where puretalk usa comes
in by the way if you go over on that six
gigs of data well
let me tell you they're not going to
charge you for it the word is out people
are abandoning their overpriced wireless
carriers they're flocking to pure talk
for the same coverage at a fraction of
the price that's right if you're with
verizon at t or t-mobile switching to
pure talk could save your family over
a year that is a lot of money and
switching is super simple again keep
your phone
keep your number get huge discounts on
the latest iphones and androids and
right now you get unlimited talk text
six gigs of data for just 30 bucks a
month go check them out right now from
your cell phone now pound 250
say ben shapiro you will save 50 off
your very first month at his pound two
five zero
say ben shapiro pure talk is simply
smarter wireless again you got a limited
talk tech six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month if you go over on data
they're not going to charge you for it
there's a reason
puretalk is the highest rated wireless
company by consumer affairs stop giving
your money so those overpriced wireless
carriers start saving money dial pound
250 on your cell phone and say ben
shapiro you'll save 50
off your first month and hundreds of
bucks over the course of the year for my
friends over at pure talk
usa okay so the american military is
now going to be rebuilt along woke lines
apparently this is the way that we are
going to do everything in america right
equity is the byword
equity is the thing that is going to
drive all biden administration
policy and there are certain
institutions in america
that i think conservatives correctly
felt were sort of biased toward
conservatives
among those institutions business which
has been completely hijacked by the woke
and now militarized against people who
think differently
the military was one of them right the
military was an institution
that generally tends to vote
conservative it is filled by people who
tend to be patriotic because you have to
be pretty patriotic to sign up
for a life of service in the american
military you tend to be pretty hawkish
on foreign policy
this is one of the great hilarities of
the left always using
the so-called chicken hawk argument is
that if somebody didn't serve in the
military they can't be hawkish on
foreign policy my response was all right
if you want to pull the members of the
american military and we will only use
their votes
i have very little doubt about which way
that is going to go okay but now
all these institutions have in fact been
taken over by the woke or at least
cudgelled in submission
by the world i don't think that the rank
and file in the military agree with what
the top
brass are doing at the military right
now but
that's of little consequence when the
people at the top of the military have
decided to mirror the priorities of the
far left the same thing is happening in
police departments around america
those police departments have been
cudgeled into silence by
left-wing federal agencies as well as by
police chiefs who are hired by
left-wing mayors and what that ends up
doing is it ends up driving good people
out of the police force it ends up
making the police force less efficient
same thing
in the military so now the military
according to the left the military is
bad when it is used as an instrument of
american foreign policy it is good when
it is used as an instrument of social
engineering so the american military is
bad when it is used in afghanistan
or iraq at that point american soldiers
become just people who are dropping
bombs on civilians as barack obama once
suggested about afghanistan
but when the american military is used
as an instrument
of instituting transgender policy or
when it is used as an instrument of
forcing forward certain policies with
regard to same-sex marriage
then it is a very good institution
because it's under total government
control
well now the american military has
decided to apparently
embrace the standards of political
correctness and not just political
correctness they've decided that the top
brass in the military are now going to
focus their fire
on public relations fights with
journalists they don't like
which is quite astounding imagine if
under president trump
top members of the american military
having heard slanderous things about
them for years from the left-wing media
like msnbc had decided you know what one
day we're just all going to go hard out
after rachel maddow rachel maddow says
something about the military and the
entire military brass decides they're
just going to go directly after rachel
maddow
a cries of authoritarianism would have
been deafening the cries of fascism
would have been deafening
why is our civilian controlled military
speaking out as an independent body
and suggesting that it should be in
competition with members of the private
sphere
and one of the great things about
america is we do have civilian control
of the military the military does not
control the military the civilian
branches of government
control the military and guess what we
all get to have opinions on how the
military is used whether or not we have
served
and none of that again is a referendum
on the bravery of the people serving as
i've said many times i didn't have the
bravery to serve there are lots of
people today
who disagree with me who have the
bravery to serve and i appreciate that
but it does not make their opinion
significantly more valuable than mine
considering my vote counts the same as
theirs
and depending on the issue perhaps i've
studied the issue
perhaps i haven't studied the issue it
doesn't really matter the bottom line is
that civilian control of the military is
one of the hallmarks of american
democracy
and one of the other hallmarks of
american democracy is the military does
not speak out as an independent body
against members of the civilian sphere
in fact it is a
regulatory violation for members of the
military to do this
they're allowed to have private based
opinions they're not allowed to speak on
behalf of the military
in members in in matters of public
policy so all of this began
last week when tucker did a segment
talking about how joe biden had been out
there bragging about how they have these
brand new uniforms for pregnant women
and the general point that tucker
carlson was making is the point of a
military is to be efficient
is to break things and kill people
basically the the job of the american
military is to make america more secure
and typically when you're talking about
the military that is through the threat
or use of violence
and top priority for a body that is
designed to do this
is not in fact the the design of new
uniforms for pregnant women
like that's all that's nice that they
have designed for uniforms for pregnant
women this isn't exactly like
the bleeding edge of what you need from
your military if you're talking about
what you need from your military it is
more firepower
it's excellent troop cohesion it is a
bit it is
high levels of efficiency in being able
to threaten or to perform
the act of breaking things and killing
people right that's what the military is
there
to do or to preserve the peace with the
threat of breaking things or killing
people
and so tucker says you know what if
we're talking about top priorities in
the military
the top priorities in the military ought
not be the maternity leave policy for
pregnant women it's great they have that
but that is not top priority and why you
have top members of the administration
touting that
as like this is the most amazing thing
happening within the military as opposed
to
here is a retrofit of all of the all of
the
obsolete equipment that the military
requires to be replaced right that
should be top priority
if you're talking about maternity leave
then maybe you ought to look to
you know some of the other federal
agencies if you even want to do that by
using the military as an instrument of
social engineering or at least
pretending that the top priority of the
military social engineering is bizarre
and does not make us more competitive
and the world came down on tucker how
dare he say this
he's sexist it's terrible that he's
suggesting all of this
right how how could he and then what's
worse is that the military
decides that they are going to get
involved in this
this is the part where things get really
wild so according to the uk independent
a top military official u.s space
command has hit out at tucker carlson's
comments against women in the military
pointing out the host has never served a
day in his life well that is true about
everybody i mean joe biden was not in
the army
so the hell what and joe biden who's
announcing the policy was it none of joe
biden's press
team was in the army and what what are
we talking about here
none of those people were marines so the
hell what that's not relevant
there's not a single host on msnbc so
far as i'm aware who's performed
military service
that's fine they're entitled to their
opinion and tucker's entitled to his
opinion
doesn't make your opinion any more or
less valuable whether you've served in
the military again if only people who
serve in the military were able to speak
out on military matters
the military would not be doing the
stuff that it's doing right now because
i promise you if you ask rank and file
americans who are in the military what
they think about the woke policy now
coming down from the top echelon of the
military they don't agree with it
they've never agreed with it by the way
so
there is a um there's this guy from
spacecom
who is um who who now
put out a a video his name is master
gunnery sergeant scott stalker
he is the command senior enlisted leader
at u.s space command
and he put out this video ripping into
tucker carlson
i understand some comments were made
yesterday and i watched the clip
that mr carlson produced as he referred
to pregnant women in the military
i'll remind everyone that his opinion
which he has a right to
is based off of actually zero days of
service in the armed forces
let's get back to work let's remember
that those opinions were made by an
individual
who has never served a day in his life
let's remember
that's all about drama tv god bless
america
semper fidelis okay i mean that's an
amazing statement when he says that
his his opinion is based off zero days
in the military again you want to pull
the members of the military donald trump
would still be president
you want to pull members of the military
i'm not sure a republican would have
lost since about 1976 maybe
okay but beyond that the basic notion
that the strength of the amount
american military is pregnant women is
not really true you want to say that
america is better off for having women
in the military
there's an argument in favor of that for
sure if you want to argue
that pregnant women are the strength of
the military that of course is very
silly
pregnant women are not the strength of
the american military giving women the
ability to take maternity leave
may be a positive and worthwhile thing
for purposes of retaining females in the
military who have volunteered to serve
but that's not the same thing as saying
that pregnant women are like the
strength of the american military that
of course is incredibly silly in fact
all of the army regulations are
precisely the opposite
army regulations say that at 20 weeks
pregnant a soldier is exempt from field
duty
they say that weight standards are made
irrelevant by pregnancy soldiers are not
available
for deployment during pregnancy if
you're the mother of a newborn for four
months after delivery until the soldier
waves
soldiers cannot be assigned to duties
when they have nausea easy exhaustion
sudden lightheadedness if that would be
hazardous to a soldier or to others that
includes all aviation duty and classes
okay again this is according to the army
regulations this is not the brutal
sexists over at fox news or something
the army has regulations that basically
wave all standards
when a woman is pregnant as they should
because when a woman is pregnant she's
not nearly in the same physical
condition
as she would be otherwise and by the way
on average women are not in the same
physical condition as men otherwise
because men have higher performance
athletically than women do on average
not
always at the bell at the end the tail
of the bell curve for a woman
is going to be above average for a man
but the tail of the bell curve from man
is way above the
the tail of the bell curve for a for a
woman
again the army regulations have
significant restrictions on what women
can and cannot do
if they are pregnant they're not
permitted to paint weld solder grind
sand on metal wash parts and perform
other duty
other duties where they are routinely
exposed to carbon monoxide soldiers
cannot participate in indoor weapons
training
you can't wear individual body armor
after 14 weeks
being pregnant upon the diagnosis of
pregnancy a soldier is exempt
from mandatory pt and from pt testing
at 20 weeks of pregnancy a soldier is
exempt from standing at parade rest or
attention for longer than 15 minutes
at 28 weeks of present pregnancy a
soldier must be provided a 15 minute
rest period every two hours
a soldier's work week is not allowed to
exceed 40 hours a soldier can't work
more than eight hours in any one day if
they are pregnant
okay so for tucker to say yeah you know
you're focusing a lot on what we do for
soldiers who are pregnant that is not
the part where we strengthen the
american military as a general policy
that is not wrong what we should be
focused on is can we win wars
in honest to god over the last week we
had a top general jack keane say there
is no guarantee that we would even win a
war against china were we to fight it
in the last 10 years right different
sponsors have run wars
on this very subject the the result is
we lose
when i was on the congressional
commission looking at the national
defense strategy in 2018 we said this
if if we entered in a war with china the
losses to personnel and high capital
assets would be on a scale not seen
since world war ii
we would be challenged to win and indeed
we could lose
okay well if that is the concern at a
certain point you know you might want to
actually
worry about the state of the military
rather than what sort of magical
performance for political correctness
purposes you are doing
and it was joe biden who decided that he
was going to do a presser about female
uniforms for pregnant soldiers
and so the point that tucker was making
is not wrong if you're focused on the
efficiency of the american military
again fine to have soldiers
who are pregnant in the military having
uniforms
i think there's a little more question
to be had about whether you ought to be
admitting soldiers who are then
going to be eligible for transition
surgery at the cost of taxpayers
that seems bizarre to me considering we
have minimum standards of getting into
the military that excludes people
who have any sort of severe mental
disorder and by the way anybody who even
has depression
right but so you can't have a depression
you can get into you can't get in the
military if you don't have depression
you can't get into the military
uh rather if you have depression you
cannot get into the military
but if you believe if you're a man who
believes you're a woman you can get into
the military and the military will then
pay for your surgery
this seems like a bizarre military
policy but beyond that like
even if that is the policy that is where
you're putting your chief focus
by the way we are all doing this at the
same time that according to the uk
telegraph
the us army is now considering a
reversal of its new gender neutral
physical test
to instead include different evaluation
categories for men and women
research showed that the army combat
fitness test which is the same for male
and female soldiers
was leading to lower results for women
with a knock-on effect for promotions
because it turns out that women and men
are not physically the same
there are also studies that have been
out for years suggesting that all male
combat units perform better than mixed
units do this according to npr 2015
a year-long marine corps study trying to
understand how gender integration would
affect combat readiness has found that
all male units were faster more lethal
and able to evacuate casualties in less
time
okay so pointing all of this out if
you're looking for combat efficiency
that's not the same as the standards
that are purported to be pushed forward
by the social engineers
okay none of that should be supremely
controversial but tucker said it so it's
controversial and not only is it
controversial you're gonna get now hit
by the military itself which is crazy
okay that's the part that's really nuts
it's not that people are giving tucker
flack these issues have long been
in the public eye the idea the top
levels the military
are now tweeting out woke talking point
slogans against tucker carlson
is nuts it's the hijacking of an
american institution that is required to
be nonpartisan for partisan purposes if
it had happened under trump they'd be
talking authoritarian
authoritarian fascism it happens under
biden and it's just considered fine and
wonderful and good for the american mill
first time the left is like the military
in like decades incredible
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you don't really want to go to that
auto parts store i know you don't you
don't want to stand in line
and then you finally get to the front of
the line and they ask you very specific
questions
and then they order the part online and
then you have to wait for weeks and then
they upcharge you or
you know you could just skip all of that
and just do it online yourself at
rockauto.com rockauto.com always offers
the lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts let's say you happen
to need
off the top of my head a delphi fg 1456
fuel pump assembly for a 2005 to 2010
honda odyssey
that'll cost you like 354 bucks at a big
chain store that is the kind of thing
you could get at rock auto for 217 bucks
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend
up to twice as much for the same parts
the rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need rockauto.com head on
over to rockauto.com right now see all
the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about xbox so they know
that we sent you okay so it wasn't just
this guy over at space com it was also
the marine corps twitter so marine corps
twitter actually targeted trump
specifically uh
targeted tucker specifically okay they
put out a tweet
of a woman carrying a man over her
shoulder and then said what it looks
like in today's armed forces tucker
carlson
get right before you get left boomer
hashtag women hashtag we are marines
tucker carlson hashtag fox news hashtag
marines hashtag currently serving
hashtag usmc women
then they followed uh somebody was like
you might want to focus more on
defeating the chinese
then you're focusing on defeating tucker
carlson and they were like
when was the last time you signed up for
service boomer
okay so it's now become taylor lorenz is
running
the the marine twitter
account apparently this is the way you
really think you're going to draw people
to the military but it isn't about
drawing people to the military it's not
about attractiveness to the military you
know how many people aren't going to
sign up because this will crap
you know how many people i get letters
from who are in the military asking
whether they should re-up because of
this woke crap and i'm not sure frankly
what to tell them because operating
under these auspices is very difficult
in the same way that if you're a cop i
got lots of emails from cops
asking you know my department has
decided that they are basically cracking
down on my ability to do my job should i
re-up
i don't know the answer to that hey what
this is not about making the military
stronger
this is of course about weaponizing the
military against political targets like
tucker carlson
and really weaponizing against an entire
side of the political aisle
if you're the chinese military you have
to be laughing at this point
right if you're america's enemies and
you are seeing that the military is
expending its resources fighting with
tucker carlson
about the the whether it is worthwhile
to
your your publicity to lead with
pregnant women
okay not whether to have women in the
military but whether the the most
important thing the military can do
right now is provide additional
maternity leave to women
and you're the chinese military and
you're looking at taking over the south
china sea you're like wow
i feel like these people don't have
their priorities in order at this point
and now for the media the media love
this kind of stuff so the media who who
have despised the military for decades
they've always seen the military as as
bad and an instrument of american
imperialism and colonialism
well now they're they're over the moon
because what they think is that they
think first of all a bunch of
traditional minded americans who love
the military
again i promise you conservatives
bipolar statistics love the military
significantly more
than members of the political left no
question and if you ask the average
conservative how many members of the
military they know the answer is going
to be a lot higher than members of the
traditional left
okay but the left seems to think that
all the people in america who love the
military are now going to turn on tucker
because they're members of the military
tweeting out pc crap
okay but that is not what's going to
happen here but the media are super
happy about it because they think that's
what's going to happen here there any
time
there is a major institution that is
gutted by the woke and then taken over
by the woke
the left are super happy about this this
is their thing and particularly when
it's militarized against their greatest
enemies over at fox news so brian
stelter
he is out there saying that you know
tucker is the new trump no here's the
thing you guys need an enemy
right trump was your enemy because trump
said things you didn't like and because
trump
boosted your ratings the ratings at cnn
have dropped precipitously since the
election
it's true for virtually all the networks
but it's dropped actually much more
precipitously for cnn than for example
msnbc
so brian stelter is saying tucker is the
new trump no you want to make tucker the
new trump so you have something to cover
there are reporters who spend all day at
cnn like media matters gurus
just sitting there monitoring fox for
bad things that they can then put on the
chirons at cnn
if you want to know what's happening on
fox all you have to do is tune over at
cnn and you'll know what's happening on
fox here's brian stelter saying
tucker is the new trump no you need to
make tucker the new trump because you
have to have trump
you have to have a trump and tucker
could be that bill burr could be that
i could be it depends on the weak today
it's tucker here's brian stelter going
after tucker
tucker carlson is the new donald trump
tucker has taken trump's place as a
right-wing leader as an outrage
generator as a fire starter
and it's all happening on fox just like
trump's campaign did
i mean think about all the ways these
two men are similar
every day carlson is throwing bombs
making online memes offending millions
of people
also delighting millions of others
tapping into
white male rage and resentment stoking
distrust of big tech in the media
generally coarsening the discourse
never apologizing for anything and
setting the gop's agenda
okay um actually you know who's setting
the gop's agenda
you guys on the left you're setting the
gop's agenda by being crazy and then
tucker comments on your crazy and then
you say that it's tucker's fault this is
the exact same thing they did with trump
don't make such a president by the way
it's crazy these people are nuts
because what they are doing is they they
do a bad thing
and then if you comment on the bad thing
you commenting on the bad thing is the
story
it's always republicans pounds it's
always tucker pounces or shapiro pounces
or look at this outrageous thing
that these right-wingers are saying in
response to us doing a crazy thing
right we ban a book and then the right
goes we don't like banning books like
look at these
polarizing terrible people talking about
banning books why aren't they focused on
policy
and then you pass a two trillion dollar
package we're like yeah that's a bad
policy that looks terrible
like how dare you criticize our policy
you're the one who are starting the fire
no i'm sorry just like trump i said over
and over and over trump
was not the murderer of american
politics he was the coroner he arrived
on the scene and the body was already
cold
the same thing is happening with tucker
he arrives on the scene there's a story
generated by joe biden it's meant to
generate a story
tucker carlson covers it and then they
lose their minds because this is what
they need to do
because everything is a search and
destroy mission tucker is an effective
communicator he must be destroyed this
is why you have april ryan
appearing on national tv to talk about
how tucker's entertainment is deadly
on cnn it's deadly okay it's not just
she disagrees
going to get people killed this is
inhumane what he's doing and we know
a judge um had to rule over tucker
carlson when his attorney
talked about him he's not a news
reporter he's an entertainer
entertainer this entertainment value of
tucker carlson
is deadly and fox news should be ashamed
of it
because people's lives are in jeopardy
we we saw the threats
that came into reality on january 6 6
because a brew a poisonous witch's brew
was stirred
by tucker carlson and others over there
okay and
this is the real goal is to get rid of
your opposition you build up your
opposition so that you can tear it down
that's the actual goal there okay in
just one second we'll get to
more of this first let us talk about the
fact that you're spending an awful lot
of time
with media these days you're watching tv
or you're listening to shows like this
one
you need a great pair of wireless
earbuds because we are not living
in 2007 it is now 2021. you need
wireless earbuds whether you're catching
up on your favorite
news podcast or binging an audiobook or
powering through your workout with a
pumped up playlist
a pair of raycons in your ears can make
all the difference no dangling wires no
stems to get in your way
raycons come in a range of stylish
colors always that comfortable in ear
fit for more discreet look raycons are
built to perform anywhere
anytime with water and sweat resistant
construction and bluetooth that pairs
quickly and seamlessly they've got
enough battery life for six hours of
playtime which means you can unplug
from that tv for quite a while the best
part raycon makes great sound accessible
to everyone with wireless earbuds
starting
at half the price of other premium audio
brands right now raycon is offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
here's what you have to do to get it go
to buy raycon dot com
slash ben again that is by raycon dot
com slash ben you get 15
off your entire raycon order so feel
free to grab a pair and a spare that is
off at buy recon dot com slash ben again
that's b y
r a y c o n dot com slash
ben okay so the culture wars that do
matter because the culture wars are in
essence political wars the democrats
have turned every single thing political
so much so that even some members of the
traditional left are looking at them
cross-eyed and going this is insane
you guys have lost it okay and as the
left pushes further and further because
they think that they now have the
ability to walk over america they
believe that they can just
they've grabbed the power in these
institutional strongholds and they're
just going to bulldoze
america they're going to generate an
outsized amount to blow back i'm not
sure that they are aware of this
or maybe they just don't care maybe they
think they can just steamroll the the
blowback but i think that's going to be
trouble for them
sarah silverman over the weekend sarah
silverman is about as far left as
possible to be campaigned for bernie
sanders
wildly anti-trump but sarah silverman
happens to be a comedian
and because she's a comedian she has
been canceled several times for
quote-unquote bad old jokes so over the
weekend she said you know what i'm
getting kind of tired
of the democratic party which has bought
into all of this stuff
i don't think that sarah silverman
speaks for no one i think she speaks for
an awful lot of people here
here's sarah silverman saying
unbelievably enough an intelligent thing
it's the absolutist
ness of the party i am in
that is such a turn off to me
it's so elitist you know for
something called progressive
it allows for zero progress
it's all or nothing no steps toward all
or
nothing again righteousness
porn and she is right about this and
this is what the left pushes
every single day because they need a
target every single day
see when you have a roving mob on the
internet waiting for the target
then you need a target it used to be
that mobs had to mobilize around
usually a terrible purpose right
everybody would
come home from work and then they would
see something bad happen and then they
would mob and do something awful and
evil
now you have a roving mob on the
internet that just spends all day on the
internet
and so the only question is around what
drop of blood are they going to
congregate
you put a drop of blood in the water and
then they all just swarm
and it's pretty obvious what kind of
culture they're attempting to build here
it's a culture
of censorious righteousness porn as she
says
that actually tolerates actual porn
right you have to understand that what
they are acting in defense of
is not a a counter culture what they are
acting in defense of is an anti-culture
that tears away all traditional
standards and so anybody who is a
defender of any element of traditional
standards up to and including
your individual right to offend that
must be torn down too
it is important that anything that
smacks of the old ways and the old ways
is not just
you know to parent household and
the white picket fence and the two two
and a half kids it's not just that
the old ways include your ability to
offend anyone if you offend anyone
then this means that you must be cast
out into the outer
into the outer realms you have to be
wished into the cornfield this is why
the grammys right it's it's it's hard to
square right
when you watched any of the grammys last
night which i don't know who did the
ratings probably were garbage
but when you watch the grammys which is
made for blue check marks on twitter
there were two competing visions that
were really at odds one was
bill burr said a thing and the thing was
unwoke
and this means that bill burt is bad and
he must trend and he is canceled because
we must never
allow anything like what bilber said to
be said ever again not in a public space
guys
bill burr has to be stopped he's a
comedian and he violated our sense of
propriety
he our puritanism the new puritans are
great with porn
and very bad with political dissidence
and if you disagree with them
then that then you must be burned at the
stake but if you want to simulate
lesbian sex acts on stage in front of
millions of people
then not only is that good that is
wonderful for our culture right so
bilber
he gets up and he makes a joke because
why the hell
and he's right he's he was there to
introduce
the best latino or latina artist or
something
and bill burr's like why am i doing this
i'm like i'm a white guy you can see all
the feminists
out there already complaining about
here's what bilber had to say and then
he trended for this
was i the only one who wanted to kill
himself during that piano solo
uh i bought a suit for this i thought it
was going to be on tv i'm such a
i am losing so much money right now and
the winner
the grammy goes to natalia laforcaydee
dude oh i will look oh sorry i will
accept on behalf of her if i butchered a
name i'm sorry
all right hey how many uh feminists are
like going nuts
why is this this white male doing all
this latino stuff
okay and people on the world club were
like it's true why is that white male
doing all this latino stuff and then
commenting on it
how dare he laughing about butchering
people's names how dare he right this is
where the puritanism comes out
because our cultural puritans can never
allow bill burr to make a joke about his
own inability to pronounce
latino names you can no le sorry latinx
names right you can never make a joke
about
that is which burning stuff right he
must be he must be burned
billboard is a bad man because he is cis
and he is
white where the h comes before the w
white
right he is a very very bad man but you
know what is great for our culture what
is great for our culture is harry styles
wara boa
because he was doing a bad david bowie
impersonation from 1986 from 1983
and and then what is also fantastic
fantastic for our culture
is extraordinarily graphic simulated
lesbian sex acts on stage
for the brand new artist of the year
megan v
stallion her given name her parents
decided that her middle name had to be v
not with one e which would make sense
she'd be megan thus stalin megan the
stallion you
are the stallion okay not just you
are
megan v the be a stallion okay so she
and cardi b simulated like full-on
pornographic act
and this has been the schtick for a
while right i mean going all the way
back to madonna let's not pretend this
is anything new the simulated sex acts
on stage at the grammys
has been quite a thing for several
decades but this was
i will say uniquely graphic right so
here was a little bit of what happened
at the grammys remember
our new puritans are great with with
porn and infecting
the culture with debauched behavior they
are fantastic with us
right they're the same people who will
say that whap is an empire in a deeply
empowering feminist song because nothing
says empowerment
quite like rapping about the moisture
state of your genitals for the pleasure
of men to consume your actual
content that that is feminism up the
wazoo
tremendous levels of feminism that is
great for our culture but if i ran the
zoo has to go guys
if i ran the zoo is deeply dangerous for
your kids if your kids
read about the island of mazurka
with a bird called the yurka your kids
will be ruined for life
deeply disturbed for life but if you
give your kid puberty blockers at
the age of five so they can decide their
gender at the age of 13 and if you
infuse the culture with a bunch of
warmed over soft core pornography on the
grammys
and then call it high culture that's not
bad for the culture that's good for the
culture this is like shakespeare
it's amazing now listen i'm not sure
that there is a
deep connection between the quality of
art that a culture produces and the
morality of the culture
right german culture produced some
wonderful highs but i will say this
i have yet to see a culture that
produces low
art and pretends that it is high art
that is worthwhile
right that is not a thing that so just
because the culture produces high art
doesn't mean the culture is good
but just because a culture produces low
art and that becomes the height of art
that's a pretty good indicator that you
have a culture and decline this is a
culture and decline right here
[Music]
and people cheering then a woman dancing
uh inside of a of a
a box in which cash is being blown at
her this is high culture guys
this is the height of our culture so if
i round the zoo very bad for your kids
don't no no if around the zoo huck finn
terrible for your children mark twain
has to go shakespeare is sexist
shakespeare is racist
shakespeare is old fashioned our new
culture however has amazing things
like this like showing on major national
television
in the evening time full-on simulated
lesbian pornography
well done everyone like just i feel our
culture is in great hands
and by the way if you make a joke about
it you ought to be canceled if you make
a joke about it
then we ought to go after your
advertisers and get you fired okay i'm
sorry but this new puritanism is not
going to stand
because it is garbage it is not even
puritanism on behalf
of some purported higher consonants with
the universe or something
it is not like i'm trying to get in
touch with deeper values i'm trying to
get in touch with my god and i can't do
that and
while these people are dissenting that's
bad enough right theocracy is bad
but this is just theocracy on behalf of
pagan garbage
okay this is theocracy on behalf of
pornography which is a very weird form
of theocracy it's just paganism and that
pagan culture
will brook no dissent everyone must be
ruined and if you cross the woke pagan
culture
then you must be destroyed this is going
to generate an awful lot of backlash
can we get to more of the destruction of
our culture because it is a thing okay
it does matter we'll get to more of that
in just one second first we have been
talking about it for a week now
this is where it gets really exciting
here at daily wire because this friday
march 19th is the premiere
of candace dailywear's new talk show
hosted by conservative lightning rod
candace owens it's no secret candace has
ruffled some feathers
along her career i would not be
surprised to see candace in another
fight with cardi b
this week because that's what candace
does now you're going to see candace
like never before in her new show
candace shows her personal side to her
guests and her live audience while she
tackles the big political and cultural
topics of the week with her signature
blend of humor and insight
don't forget canada starts this friday
march 19th and it will be exclusive to
daily wire if you aren't a member yet go
to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candice for 25 off
that's dailywire.com
subscribe use code candice for 25
of so much exciting stuff going on at
daily wire if you're not a member you're
really missing out
my brand new series debunked this week
we debunked many of the transgender
myths on debunked
you're going to want to subscribe before
that you want to subscribe so you can
have access to run hide fight you want
to subscribe so that when gina carano's
new movie comes out you have access to
that
plus we have all access right you can
hang out with each of our hosts
so much good stuff happening for
subscribers right now go to
dailywire.com subscribe use code candice
for 25 percent off you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
i mean there has to be a limit to this
right but we're not going to reach that
limit for quite a while
remember i've been reporting to you
thanks to producers savvy and jessica
i've been
on top from the beginning of this
bachelor controversy
in which chris harrison got himself into
super giant hot water why
for the great sin of defending a
bachelor contestant named rachel kirk
connell because a few years ago she went
to some sort of
antebellum-themed costume party and
because it was an antebellum themed
costume party this meant that they were
neglecting the evil sins of
of slavery now again slavery the great
evil of
of american history no question also
wearing a floofy dress from 1850 does
not mean
that you are in fact a fan of slavery
that's an absurdity it's like saying
that because you dressed up as george
washington for halloween one year you're
a fan of slavery like this is
i'm sorry no it is true that people who
dress like that
held slaves it is also true that people
dress up as people throughout history
who have been in cultures that held
slaves in fact if you pick any culture
prior to about
sixteen hundred chances are there was
slavery in that culture
okay but beyond that he didn't even
defend
the behavior chris harrison he just said
maybe you should grant her some grace
maybe she didn't know that this was
offensive maybe you should just leave
her alone
and not mob her maybe you shouldn't go
after her parents in their voting record
and you know who else said this the
other person who said this was the guy
she was dating
at the time who happened to be the
bachelor she won right she ended up
being
the bachelorette harrison then did an
ill-advised interview
with a woke former bachelorette and
during that interview he said that she
needed to have a little grace
right he said we all need to have a
little grace a little understanding a
little compassion i've seen some of the
stuff online this judge jury executioner
thing where parents are just tearing
this girl's life apart and diving into
like her parents voting record it's
unbelievably alarming
to watch this he was then issued he was
forced to issue an apology
and then a second apology but now it
turns out that chris harrison will no
longer
be actually hosting the show at all
that is after he did another one of
these muelling interviews the good
morning america
in which he announced he was taking
drastic steps to save his job including
lessons with a race educator
he was going to get the woke
re-education and that still wasn't
enough his job is still gone
show producers announced that he was
being permanently replaced at least as
host of the bachelorette the female
version of the show
the outlet reported chris harrison will
not host the next season of the
bachelorette for the first time in the
history of the franchise which began as
a guilty pleasure when it debuted in
2002.
we are dedicated to improving the bypa
representat representation of our crew
including among the executive producer
ranks said warner and abc these are
important steps in affecting fundamental
change so that our franchise is a
celebration of love
that is reflective of our world yes
nothing says a reflection of love quite
like forcing somebody to lose his job
for suggesting that perhaps you should
have grace for other human beings
the backlash when this comes is going to
be significant and then of course when
there is a backlash it will be
attributed
to racism and sexism and brutality and
homophobia and all the rest
because that's the way our stupid
culture works
the way that the way that all of this
works is that the left does something
extreme
and extraordinary while mainstreaming a
bunch of fringe behavior
and then when you protest they say it's
because you're a bad person
americans are going to stand for this up
to the point where they don't stand for
it anymore and when the backlash comes
it is going to be incredibly strong but
good news before the backlash comes the
democrats are going to take advantage
of the fact that they have the
commanding heights of all of our
institutions and the government
to ram through everything they could
possibly want
and in order to do that they also have
to prolong the crisis that they believe
we are in with regard to covet now let's
make this clear we are not in a crisis
anymore with regard to covet icu's
around the country
are threatened nowhere there's not a
single place in the united states where
icu's are
under threat of being overwhelmed there
are still a lot of coveted patients that
are coming in they tend to be
mainly younger and less severe because a
huge percentage of the elderly in
america's elderly states places like
florida are already vaccinated
the vaccines are going out an
extraordinary rate we're doing about 2
million shots a day
this crisis is drawing to an end but in
order to ram through
massive government policy the left has
to pretend that the crisis is never
going to end
and they're already starting to morph
this right so they're already starting
to say well it's no longer a coveted
crisis now
there's the possibility that climate
change will be the big problem right
this is how you have chuck todd
saying you know what sure this pandemic
might be coming to an end
but we need more government spending and
we need to build back better because
you know there could be more pandemics
in the future because of climate change
remember before this
the the suggestion was we needed to
overthrow the structure of the american
economy
because of climate change and income
inequality then it turned out
that actually the best possible response
to income change
income inequality and climate change it
turns out is actually more capitalism in
a lot of circumstances
not less capitalism but the left is
pushing that as the crisis
now this crisis appears to be winning so
chuck todd is saying you know what we'll
have more pandemics because of climate
change so
maybe we should continue doing this
stuff you know when you think about
sadly having to prepare for this again
right and i know there's a lot of folks
who
who think that you know due to climate
change and due to
the globalization in general it's
inevitable we're going to
deal with more and more viruses like
this
the biggest lesson you're you're going
to take away to prepare for the next one
okay it's um the the desire to prolong
the crisis is obvious and
captain crisis here is uh dr anthony
factory the second greatest doctor in
america after dr joe biden
who if you have a heart attack will
immediately diagnose you with a
community college degree
dr fauci was on with chuck todd and he
was explaining
that you know what we're just going to
continue this we're going to continue to
pretend that this crisis is a crisis
he says i can't tell you when we can
schedule weddings and doors
he can't i can you know when you can
schedule a wedding indoors
right now and if people don't want to
show they don't have to show you can
schedule a wedding indoors right now
and if you're vaccinated you don't have
to worry about it the cdc standards say
that if you are vaccinated and you are
in contact with a person
who is positive for covet 19 you do not
even have to quarantine which means that
they are not worried that you are going
to pass along the disease by the way
that's what the studies show from israel
they show
that the rates of transmission for
people who have already been vaccinated
and have the antibodies
are extremely low if you're a vaccine
and if you and if you've had the
opportunity to get a vaccine
and you are not vaccinated at that point
that one's on you
i can tell you right now when people are
going to start rescheduling weddings
indoors and the answer is over the
course of the next month and a half
by the time that we it is already
mid-march by the time we hit the
beginning of
of april there are going to be people
starting to schedule weddings and by the
time we hit the beginning of may
there will be full-scale indoor weddings
but here is fouchy saying i can't tell
you when to schedule a wedding indoors
maybe never
maybe not guess what no this is still
a free republic supposedly we are not
going to listen to you just because
40 years ago you were appointed the head
of a government agency
i will say the the amount of respect the
media have for fauci is not matched in
any sense by the amount of respect that
people in private sector medicine have
for dr fauci
it is not a thing okay here is dr fauci
saying that basically
you know he'll give you permission when
you can go back to having weddings
when can people plan an indoor wedding
you know that's it that's a good
question and i think that's going to be
within a reasonable period of time
you notice what the cdc is doing they
gave
excuse me i didn't need this calendar
what time of the year i
you know i i can't give you that exact
date because it's going to absolutely
depend and this gets back to
our conversation a minute or two ago
it's going to depend on the level of
infection in community
okay so he can't tell you also he says
there will be a degree of normality by
the summer
what degree he can't tell you our our
scientific establishment has been
corrupted by politics we've talked about
the military being corrupted by politics
our culture has been completely
destroyed by politics
and we also now have the scientific
community destroyed by politics it is
incredible to me
that we spent a year suggesting that
trump was tearing the heart out of the
scientific community
while he was allowing voucher to go on
tv and spout whatever fouch you wanted
to say
and yet the biden administration is
clearly and
obviously and openly changing cdc
standards to match their political
priors
and the entire media's like oh well i
guess they're following the science no
it is the opposite here's anthony factor
saying well we'll have a degree of
normality by the summer no we're not
going to have a degree of normality by
the summer we are going to have
normality by the summer period end of
story
there are two issues getting enough
doses which we will have
with the new contracts with the
pharmaceutical companies
but once you get those doses to get it
into people's arms
and that's the reason why when the
president said by the fourth of july
we'll be we'll believe strongly that if
we do all these things
we'll reach a certain degree of
normality by then and then well into the
summer we'll get even better and better
towards normal it's amazing how he
turned toward the positive attack by the
way
as soon as this giant useless and
counterproductive stimulus
act passed okay that thing is replete
with pork and we all know the actual
priorities here again prolong the crisis
so you can continue to force forward all
sorts of insane spending here's nancy
pelosi
talking about the bailout to unions so
there's a 90 billion dollar bailout to
private sector unions in this thing
they'd sign bad contracts with their
companies their pension funds were
running out of money because they were
predicated on false promises
and now you the taxpayer you get to pick
up the check for that so nancy pelosi
says
the bailout to the unions was about the
children and also their grandparents
and also their grandparents in other
words yes we are just paying off our
chief constituencies and we're
pretending it's about the crisis but it
ain't here's nancy pelosi
i've always said that the three most
important issues facing the congress are
our children our children our children
their health their education the
economic security of their families
including the pension security for their
grandparents
and a environment in which they can
thrive
safely world at peace in which they can
reach their fulfillment
well the first three of those their
health their education
and the economic security of their
families was very much
affected by the biden american rescue
plan again they're just going to keep
talking this thing up plus you know
what's coming on the other end what
democrats really want which is higher
taxes
that's what democrats really want and
the great lie they will tell you is that
they're gonna not raise taxes on anybody
except the super wealthy the super
wealthy can't pay for all this
no one can can pay for all this you
could confiscate every dollar of wealth
from the top one percent in america and
redistribute it today
and it would not dent america's national
debt it would not dent the kind of
spending that we are doing right now
here is nancy pelosi openly embracing
the idea of raising taxes down the line
again there are going to be consequences
for the spending binge
that we have all decided to go along
with here i'm glad that we have decided
as a culture
that the giant gaping hole in our hearts
left as a result of the death of
religion and community
can be filled with puritanical wokeness
ridiculous hedonism on tv and government
stimmy checks but it can't it ain't
gonna cure anything all that's gonna
come on the other end is pain including
increases in taxes for people in the
middle i love how people wanna have
european styles of living but without
having to pay european taxes if you earn
over 60 grand a year here's nancy pelosi
you signal friday that major
infrastructure legislation is coming
next that's going to require
new taxes can you keep democrats united
behind a proposal like that and attract
any republican support
well we'll see i mean but it is going to
take new taxes right you say fiscally
sound
well we'll see there's some some fees
that spring from certain
uh harbor tech maintenance tax
credits this that we'll see it i think
that some of it
uh needs to be well we'll look at
everything
oh yeah they will look at everything and
bottom line is this there's a piece in
the new york times today
about the era of bill clinton being over
and that's right the era of bill clinton
is over because bill clinton was a
democrat who embraced the basic notion
that the era of big government was over
the arab big government is back it's
sucked in the 60s it's going to be even
worse now
at least in the 60s there's an argument
to be made that you're trying to rectify
deep and abiding american imbalances at
this point all you're attempting to do
is cram down a socialistic version of
big government
in which government and corporations
work hand in hand to destroy your
freedoms
and to restrict competition in favor of
some sort of
bizarre version of utopia in which
you're not allowed to speak freely and
the government hands you a check
that is the direction in which we're
moving alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out the
michael moles show on today's episode
michael will be talking about the
possibility of meghan markle running for
office
quick note there by the way i predicted
that a year ago i said in january 2020
that meghan markle wanted to run for
president
and now they're talking about that so i
have to stop joking things into reality
it's really a problem
that episode is available right now i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam scievents audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
a military later attacks a conservative
journalist for suggesting that
maybe pregnant women don't make the best
soldiers
tom cotton turns a libs racial attack
against her
and a leftist comedienne rips the
democrat party check it out on the
michael knowles show